there we go and here we go off the draw
lomberg against McBain badic was looking
to see if he would go with O'Brien Ryan
lomberg doesn't take many face
offs and really didn't take that
one oh there's some Haymakers being
thrown right
there now keep in mind that's not Zucker
so when lomberg went over to Zucker they
were chatting in the pregame others came
over so there's the first fight of the
night and we'll see if it's the only one
at the 5sec
[Applause]
Mark number
22 number 94 Arizona Florida both guys
for 5 each
fighting putting the mustard on it you
don't put you don't see it very often
but uh this is a little car over from
the first meeting as we just showed you
and the Panthers are a team that sticks
together and there you see as soon as
they drop the
puck all right so now Kevin stenland
comes on to take the actual faceof
perhaps it's Lawson Krauss we I think
we're going to go again we're going to
go again here we go and here's O'Brien
and gvic now squaring up at Center ice
so you saw the chatter the pregame
warm-ups two fights in the first s
seconds these are two guys that know
what they're doing and they're sizing
each other
[Applause]
up both grab
[Music]
on O'Brien he leads the NHL in penalty
minutes and now we look at gich he's not
very happy that the linesman jumped
in so that's two so far well and the
reason is folks that O'Brien and gadit 3
didn't drop the gloves the same time as
the as the first fight with lomberg
involved is that's an automatic game
misconduct so you don't want to do that
but they knew they were going to go as
soon as they dropped the
puck that's center stage at Center
Ice the officials are going over to both
benches now we'll see how this thing
materialized again all this goes back to
zucker's dirty hit on Nick cousins
knocking him out he hasn't played since
and that was 3 weeks ago
yeah